hot breath this comes from uh
justin williams and he asks
uh do you give a closer listen to
your opener to gauge what set you're
going to do
no i um i will sometimes i don't listen
at all
if i do listen it's only to see if we're
doing any of the same topics
um but no i don't i don't
definitely i'm not going to gauge the
audience based on how the opener
does what do you what do you gauge the
audience how do you like read a crowd
i don't i mean i do it once i get on
stage
i don't plan ahead because you know
people will surprise you
it will not it won't be what you think
right so so i'll be
somewhere in the deep south and somebody
fully agrees on an uh a joke about
guns where you'd expect somebody in the
south to be all pro-gun or whatever you
know see
you really you never know who's
listening never know who's laughing
never know what they're laughing at uh
i'll give you a great story so
i was hired to do um
a joke they did this woman asked me i
i forgot where i knew but anyway she
said would you be interested in doing a
show for a sorority
and it's like hell yeah right yeah a
bunch of women at college sure
this is my younger days uh-huh so uh i
get to the show
i get to the show and it's this room
full of old women
and the sorority was they raise money
for charities
and they give money to charity right so
the first comment goes up
and he dies a horrible death
i mean just because he's trying to
figure out
what do you joke to a room full of old
women about you know
so the next comic's up and he is also
just it's just watching a sinking ship
which is always fun
to watch somebody else
the woman leans over to me the woman
leans over me and she said and this
woman is
in her 60s and she's one of the younger
women
at this event and she leans over she
says listen
these guys are worried about what to say
said
you know how all us women met she said
we used to send the boys off to war
if you know what i mean
they were a bunch of dirty old women it
was hilarious
so once i knew that then i could go
you know and they loved it and they
laughed and they had a good time
so again when you talk about reading the
audience
the the thing about being a comic is you
got to learn to listen
everyone thinks it's talking it's
listening you gotta learn to listen you
listen to what the crowd laughs at you
listen to what they react to
then you know who you're talking to but
trying to just come out and read and say
this is gonna be this
is gonna be that also and once again
what are you gonna do are you gonna
change your whole act because you think
this crowd is blank
so now you're gonna try to rewrite 45
minutes in your head like no
that's not going to happen so you got to
do what you do
you know uh that you're not going to be
a different person
you know watch bill burr in
philly okay watch go to youtube
look up bill burr in philly and watch
how to handle
a crowd that doesn't like you
that clip is famous that clip is famous
you do you as the kids say
you